Histogram normalization is a common technique
that is used to enhance fine detail within
an image.
The cumulative histogram is computed from
the image intensity histogram.
Each column in the cumulative histogram is
computed as the sum of all the image intensity
histogram values up to and including that
grey level, and then it is scaled so that
the final value is 1.0.
And what you will notice with the cumulative
histogram is that it is very steep when the
input histogram is quite large, and it is
fairly flat when the input histogram is quite
low.
So we can see here a couple of areas where
the cumulative histogram has grown quite quickly.
Now we use the cumulative histogram as a mapping.
So for every input value, and these unsigned
integer pixel values in the range 0 to 255,
I take an input pixel x and I map it through
the cumulative histogram and I get the result.
So my function of x is a non-linear mapping
through the cumulative histogram of the image.
So the result of this on the Mona Lisa image
is to enhance a lot of the fine detail.
So if we have a look into the background we
can see areas where it is fairly dark in the
original image and where the histogram normalization
has increased the local contrast; made it
possible for us to see detail that otherwise
we could not see very easily in the input
image.
This is another example of a monadic image
processing operation.